The last step here is how
do we learn a model for R?
Now remember,
when we execute an action a in state s,
we get an immediate reward, little r.
So again, big R, s,
a as are expected reward if we're
in state s and we execute action a.
Little r is our immediate reward when
we experience this in the real world.
So big R is our model, little r is
what we get in an experience tuple.
So we want to update this model every
time we have a real experience.
And it's a simple equation, very much
like the q table update equation.
What we have is one minus alpha
where alpha is our learning rate and
again that can typically be
something like zero point two.
Anyways we multiply that times
our current value for R and
then we add in of course our new
estimate of what that value ought to be.
And we just use r for the new estimate.
So it's alpha times little r,
which is our immediate reward, or
our new best estimate of
what the value should be,
plus what the value was
before times 1 minus alpha.
So we're waiting presumably.
Our old value more than our new value,
so we converge more slowly.
But that's it.
That's a simple way
to build a model of R
from observations of interactions
with the real world.